hello and thank you for having me today
my name is renee delotter and i am the
deputy to the cannabis program here at
hla
today i will be discussing the current
cannabis testing legislation and testing
changes
in the united states i will also talk
about the hemp testing as it pertains to
the usda's final rule
before i get started i want to talk a
little bit about a2la
and what we do typically i'm asked three
things about a2la and
general accreditation what does atla do
what is iso iec 7225 accreditation
and what allows us to accredit labs so
let me start by explaining
who we are and what we do american
association for laboratory accreditation
or a2la is an accreditation body in the
united states
we are an organization that provides
accreditation services which is a
third party recognition of competence
to perform specific tasks such as
laboratory testing
we are among the largest accreditation
body in the u.s and one of the largest
in the world
currently there are over 3 800
certificates in the directory of
accredited organizations
what is iso iec 17025 accreditation
iso iec 17025 accreditation
is a standard used for testing and
calibration laboratories
laboratories that get assessed to this
include food and beverage labs
environmental labs and cannabis labs
iso iec 17025 enables laboratories to
demonstrate
that they operate competently and
generate valid results
thereby promoting confidence in their
work both nationally
and around the world this accreditation
also helps laboratories by
generating wider acceptance of results
between countries
test reports and certificates can be
accepted from one country to another
without the need for further testing
which in turn provides which in turn
improves
international trade why can we assess
and accredit
as an accreditation body we are full
members of ilac
and signatories of the mutual
recognition agreement
accreditation bodies that are
signatories of the ilac mra
have been peer evaluated in accordance
with the requirements of iso
iec 17011 to demonstrate their
competence
so we also are held to a standard to be
able to assess and accredit laboratories
now that i've given you some background
on what we do i'll go ahead and jump
into the united states cannabis
regulations
i just wanted to start by giving a brief
overview of where our country stands by
providing a breakdown of each state's
legal status
when it comes to cannabis cannabis does
include both hemp and marijuana but for
the purpose of this presentation
it can be considered high thc cannabis
currently 16 states have legalized high
thc cannabis
for recreational use these states are
the blue states shown on the map
this includes oregon washington state
california
nevada arizona colorado montana south
dakota
illinois michigan new jersey
massachusetts vermont
maine and alaska the darker green states
are states which have legalized medical
use cannabis
many of these states have a list of
medical conditions that qualify patients
for medical use cannabis
the light green states have legal
medical use cannabis but still limited
thc
this would be your hemp and your cbd
products
the states that have the red letter d on
them are the states that have
decriminalized cannabis
this is not the same as legalization the
states that have decriminalized cannabis
typically have a legal limit for
instance maryland you can possess up to
10 grams of cannabis
with no penalty but with possession of
more than 10 grams includes fines and
potential jail time
on the flip side the united states is a
lot more friendly toward temp
cultivation and sales occurring in their
states
currently the only state that does not
allow for hemp to be cultivated is idaho
additionally washington dc and the
united states territories also do not
allow hemp to be grown
some of these states have their own hemp
plans approved by the usda
whereas some states do not have anything
in place yet requiring testing
i will talk more about the usda final
rule on the later slide
so despite the pandemic 2020 was a
rather successful year in the cannabis
industry
both hawaii and ohio decriminalized
cannabis hawaii's possession limit is
now 3 grams being the smallest legal
limit in the u.s
and ohio has doubled the amount of
cannabis consider
cannabis considered a mismeter from 100
to 200 grams
vermont legalized recreational youth
cannabis becoming the 11th state to
legalize
tax and regulate recreational cannabis
and arizona
and oklahoma passed legislation
requiring testing for cannabis products
continuing with successes in the
industry during the 2020 election there
were five states that had
cannabis regulations on their ballots
all five states passed their
proposed legislation arizona montana
and new jersey passed legalization for
adult use cannabis
mississippi passed legalization for
medical use cannabis
and south dakota passed both
legalization of medical and adult use
many of you probably heard these five
states pass some sort of legalization
during the 2020 election so i wanted to
provide a brief update on each
of these states and where they are in
the process of legalization
the state of arizona waited no time at
all to release adult
adult use regulations arizona department
of health services who oversees the
medical program
and who will now oversee the adult use
program is now accepting applications
from existing medical cannabis license
holders
seeking to operate in the adult use
market
the state of new jersey has officially
signed their bill into law and they are
now working on license requirements for
growers distribu
distributors testing laboratories and
other requirements for testing labs
currently new jersey does not require
laboratories to be iso iec
1725 accredited for medical marijuana
testing
so it'll be interesting to see if it
becomes a requirement for recreational
use laboratories
meanwhile in mississippi montana and
south
montana and south dakota things haven't
gone so smoothly
opponents to legalization in all three
states have filed lawsuits
challenging the voter approved laws on
procedural grounds
many states did not have the time or
resources to move forward with ballot
initiatives due to the pandemic
and this and state shutdowns however
some states are pursuing
legalization because of the pandemic
both connecticut and pennsylvania have
been pushing for legalization
for recreational youth cannabis to
create revenue and jobs in their states
one study conducted by the connecticut
center of economic analysis suggested
that connecticut
could create 10 to 17 000 jobs and 690
to 740 million dollars in state
tax revenue over five years of sales
cannabis legalization measures are
already off to a great start for 2021.
there are already at least eight states
this year that have bills pushing for
some sort
of cannabis legalization including both
connecticut and pennsylvania
other states that have begun 2021
initiatives include
maryland nebraska new mexico north
dakota virginia and wyoming
i want to dive a little bit deeper into
what each state's initiative looks like
connecticut has introduced bill fb888
this will regulate this will legalize
and regulate adult use cannabis
the bill is expected to move forward
with the with amendments
but there have been no formal proposed
amendments yet
maryland has introduced hb 32 this bill
will
legalize and regulate adult use cannabis
from what it looks like this bill is in
the judiciary committee
with no amendments formally proposed yet
nebraska received enough signatures in
2020
to put medical marijuana on the 2020
ballot however
nebraska's supreme court stripped the
medical marijuana constitutional
amendment
from the 2020 ballot due to the question
being
confusing and creating voter doubts and
that it violated the single subject
requirement
of a constitutional question nebraskans
for
medical marijuana have submitted a new
petition for 2022
and the signature drive will start in
the spring of 21.
in the meantime the bill lb 474 was
introduced to legalize medical cannabis
through the nebraska unicameral
legislator
in february new mexico house of
representatives approved a bill to
legalize cannabis for adult use
now the senate will work to unify three
competing bills
in 2020 north dakota did not receive
enough signatures
to get legalization for adult use on the
ballot
but they are trying again this year they
will need to get enough signatures to
put this on the ballot on the 2022
ballot
meanwhile lawmakers in north dakota are
pushing for further
reduced harsh and senseless penalties
for adults caught with small amounts of
marijuana
in pennsylvania for the first time a bar
a bipartisan pair of senators
have introduced a bill that would
legalize cannabis for adult use
the bill has not been formally
introduced but this would allow
adults 21 and older to purchase and
possess cannabis from licensed realtors
virginia house and senate voted to
approve a final compromise
on the adult use legislation bill this
is now
waiting on the governor's approval both
possession and cultivation of cannabis
will not become legal for adults until
january 1st
2024 in wyoming hb0209 was assigned on
march 2nd
this bill would legalize possession
homegrown and sales for adults
as well as establish a regulatory
framework for licensing tracking and
taxation
here are some states that are predicted
to have cannabis
legislation on the 2022 ballot arkansas
florida missouri
ohio and oklahoma are predicted to have
adult youth cannabis
on their ballots and idaho is predicted
to have medical use cannabis on their
ballot
one thing to note here is that all the
states that are potentially going to
have adult use cannabis
on their 2022 ballot all require iso iec
17025 accreditation for their medical
programs
i did want to spend a minute on
washington dc and their initiative for
legalization
as it is unique the initiative is called
initiative 71.
this would legalize cannabis and allow
d.c to tax and regulate the industry
because dc is not a state and is
considered federal
property they do not tax and regulate as
states do
this has made it more difficult to pass
cannabis legislation
due to cannabis being federally illegal
in this case congress must vote on
legalization
and it has been turned down continuously
so what do we so what do the current
testing requirements look like in the
u.s
there are currently no federal testing
requirements for cannabis
each state is in charge of making their
own regulations
and requirements but testing is not
always required
some requirements for cannabis include
being accredited to iso iec
step 2025 by an ilac recognized
accreditation body
i want to emphasize why ilac recognized
accreditation body is important to note
as i mentioned in my introduction about
a-l-a
we as an accrediting body have
requirements we have to meet as well
this way there is a competent
accreditation body assessing appropriate
requirements for testing labs
other requirements include required
tests such as pesticides
potencies heavy metal and microbials and
the limits of detection for each test
required to pass license is also
required some states require labs to
hold a state license
to test cannabis as well
i want to expand on states requiring iso
iec
1725 accreditation many people want to
know
why is this important like i mentioned
there are no federal regulations for
cannabis currently
in the u.s so with each state making
their own regulation
iso iec 17025 accreditation
bring some standardization to the
cannabis testing industry
i want to highlight the iso iec 17025
accreditation specifically
because there are many other
accreditations out there
iso iec 17025 accreditation
is recognized internationally and builds
off the quality requirements
for iso 9001 but adds technical
competency requirements for labs
this is super important for cannabis
labs considering there are very few
standard methods for
testing cannabis there are sections in
the standard that require complete
validations
labs need not only the complete method
validations but authorization of staff
to be able to validate these methods
evidence of training
passing proficiency tests and that's
just to name a few elements required
other significant areas of the standard
include competency requirements of
personnel
and sampling requirements for labs
so why are states leaning towards third
party iso accreditation
legalization is so very new in the
united states and many states don't have
the resources to self-regulate
this industry appropriately because this
is such a new industry states have put
regulations in place
that have that they have later found
were not appropriate or sufficient for
this industry
iso iec 17025 is a worldwide known
standard
that many other industries use for
regulations
having a standard to follow helps build
confidence in the cannabis industry
so why would customers such as growers
dispensaries and consumers
want testing requirements it helps to
minimize risk
iso iec 17025 accreditation helps ensure
test results are accurate and enhances
customers trust
in the tested product by assuring them
that it has been
thoroughly evaluated by an independent
competent testing laboratory
that has been assessed by a third party
this is only a handful of states but i
wanted to highlight a few states to show
the variation of testing requirements
from state to state
arizona oklahoma and texas have not
required iso
iec 17025 accreditation in the past but
are now adding this to their cannabis
testing requirements
all three states are at different places
of legalization as well
arizona has legalized recreational use
oklahoma legalized medical use only
and texas has legalized cbd or hemp
products only
as you can see alaska and illinois are
legal for recreational use
but neither require iso accreditation
but states like maine nevada and now
vermont all have legalized recreational
use cannabis
and do require testing labs to have iso
iec
1785 accreditation new jersey maryland
and pennsylvania all have medical
cannabis programs
but iso iec's 17025 accreditation is not
required in new jersey
but is required in both maryland and
pennsylvania like i mentioned new jersey
has
just passed legalization for
recreational use but there's still no
requirements for iso iec
1705 accreditation yet
oregon is pretty unique when it comes to
testing cannabis they have their own
state accreditation program called orlap
warlab stands for oregon environmental
laboratory accreditation program
so they do not require cannabis labs to
seek accreditation from an iloc or
creation body
this program is what environmental labs
in oregon are assessed to
there's a little bit of controversy
about this because they also make
cannabis labs meet tni requirements
for example pt requirements are quite
stringent compared to iso requirements
tni requires labs to do pt of their
whole scope with the all analytes
included twice a year
this is very costly for labs that cannot
receive federal funding
most states do require some sort of
testing and do have testing requirements
even if iso iec 1725 accreditation is
not a requirement
i want to point out that in 2020 both
arizona and oklahoma went from not
requiring iso
iec 72025 accreditation to requiring it
i want to expand on why testing is now
required many states including both
arizona and oklahoma
legalized medical cannabis and didn't
exactly know where to go from there
in oklahoma they legalized medical
cannabis in 2018
but did not have any specific
requirements in place for this
they later realized they needed to add
specific testing requirements
like heavy metals microbials mycotoxins
thc potency
and a few others along with requiring
iso iec
17025 accreditation
the iso iec 7225
17025 standard is also easier to follow
considering
many other industries use this standard
you used to be able to get a license
before accreditation now you must get
accredited to get a state license
there are pros to cons there are both
pros and cons to this
a pro for requiring accreditation before
testing
or receiving a license is that
laboratories are being assessed
and being deemed competent before
testing customer samples
some cons for requiring accreditation
before testing
or receiving a license is cost most labs
do not have revenue before
they start testing so this is a big
upfront cost
assessors are not viewing any customer
generated data such as cfas
since the laboratory is not actually
testing also the validations are not
done with
in-matrix samples which could affect
results
states tend to evolve testing
requirements when they notice public
health trends such as recalls and
illnesses
for example in 2019 states started
noticing that there were an increased
number of people having respiratory
complications
due to vaping after further
investigation they later found that
vitamin e acetate was being used to cut
vaping products
this test is now required testing in
both maryland and michigan
as for recalls this could happen if some
someone found mold or foreign matter
in a product that has already gone to
shelf
some states in some states products are
also required to be
tested after they have been packaged and
are already ready to purchase
this is due to contaminants such as
microbials growing on
the product due to poor packaging or
storing oklahoma is just one state
adopting the system
several other states have revised their
testing requirements
in the past couple of years to require
additional testing
california expanded the panel of
required tests three times in 2018 alone
the in colorado now requires heavy
metals pesticides
and microbials to be tested
okay so now i'm going to move on from
cannabis to the usda
hemp final rule so what prompted the
usda to get involved
in the united states the usda regulates
agricultural exports
and goods which now includes hemp hemp
is now being cultivated for many
purposes
in the u.s including manufacturing
manufacturing cbd and cbg products
some of the primary decisions made in
this rule include dea certification
this requirement means that all hemp
testing labs must be registered with the
dea to test hemp
labs have until december 31 2022 to get
registered
this requirement is still unclear as
some labs that are testing marijuana
were previously dea registered
additional guidance is needed for labs
that are testing both hemp and marijuana
as it is likely that they will need to
pick one
the final rule establishes performance
bait
establishes performance-based sampling
requirements states are given
flexibility
to achieve performance objectives that
they desire
such as a reliability of 95 percent
some states do require licensing and iso
accreditation for hemp testing
and sampling one state that does this is
colorado
samples must be collected by usda
approved sampling agent the usda will
provide a list of authorized sampling
agents on their website
sampling agents must be trained under
the applicable usda or state training
procedures
the requirements for testing total thd
instead of
limiting the testing to delta 9 thd has
also not been changed
laboratories should meet the aoac
international standard
method performance requirements for
selecting an appropriate method
to determine mu they encourage states
to monitor review and evaluate mu
determine trends and outliers which may
indicate
quote unquote lab shopping for higher
emus
why is mu important a sample could be
borderline pass fail and mu could help
determine if a sample
needs to be retested or not usda is not
adopting requirements that hemp testing
laboratories must be approved under a
usda laboratory approval program
or undergo iso accreditation state plans
are free to include
additional requirements for hemp testing
laboratories including iso accreditation
or other certifications this decision
was largely based on cost
to recap the u.s is slowly but surely
making progress in legalization
and regulation of cannabis testing
although many states have pushed
cannabis
initiatives to a later date it still
looks promising for the future